last but not least is resilience I do
think that it is extremely important
that you develop some resilience
techniques for yourself because
otherwise the stress and the pressure
that you will certainly face on many of
these Consulting projects will be very
difficult for you to handle if you do
not have good resilience techniques in
place it is just the truth there are
many Consulting projects will be faced
with a significant workload and then
also additional pressure imposed On You
by clients and sometimes even also your
team being successful in Consulting is a
marathon it is not a Sprint so you need
to make sure that you do not burn out
and have a plan have techniques in place
that will carry you through it in the
long term